ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BAKER
FORGES BRADFORD BY ADAM
CORTEZ'S DALLY DODD TORONTO
EGGMAN GROSS HERTZBERG HUESO
HURTADO JONES LAYERED LEYVA
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ NEWMAN NIELSEN
A CHILL OF BOTH PAN PORTANTINO
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER NUMBER
WHITE HOUSE SKI WIENER WILK
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITHIN WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL
BE LEADING PER THIS AFTERNOON
BY SENATOR BACKER AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR MELENDEZ CENTER BETTER
GOD OF LOVE AND UNDERSTANDING
WE PRAY THIS DAY IN THE WORDS
OF THE RIGVEDA LET US BE UNITED
BUT A SPEAK AND HARMONY BUT
OUR MINDS APPREHEND ALIKE
COMMANDEER PRAYER COMMENT THE
END OF OUR GATHERING CAN I BE
A RESOLUTION COMMENT BE OUR
DELIBERATIONS I LIKE THE OUR
FEELINGS UNIFIED DEAR HEARTS
BERMAN DEAR INTENTIONS EIGHT B.
R.
UNITY AMEN
SENATORS PLEASE PLACE
YOUR RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR
HEART READY BEGIN I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR
WHICH IT STANDS ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL
MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE
SENATORS BATES GLAZER
GONZALEZ MEMOTONG MEN AND
STERN PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS
THE MOVING ON MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS IN NOTICES
THREE NINE MOVE ON TO
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST
READING OF BILLS SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL
TWO FORTY NINE TO FIFTY AND
SENATE BILL TWO FIFTY ONE
THANK YOU NOW MEMBERS MOVING
TO CONSIDERATION THE DAILY
FILE WE HAVE SENATE SECOND
READING ITEM ONE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL TWENTY
NINE THANK YOU IF THERE'S
NO OTHER BUSINESS SENATOR
ATKINS THE DESK IT'S CLEAR
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES FIVE THIS VERY SHORT
SESSION DOES NOT MEAN WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF WORK PLANNED FOR
THIS WEEK SO I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE YOU KNOW THAT AND MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU -- ARE
SESSION FULLER SESSION NEXT IS
SCHEDULED FOR THURSDAY JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY
ONE I SHOULD HAVE BROUGHT
MY GLASSES AT NINE AM AND BE
PREPARED FOR THIS THURSDAY
TO GO A LITTLE LONGER I WANT
TO MAKE SURE YOU HEAR ME NOW
WHEN I SAY WE'VE GOT A NUMBER
OF ITEMS -- THE WORK BEGINS
WE KNEW WE WOULD RAMP UP AND
IT SHALL AND I WILL SEE YOU
THURSDAY AT NINE AM THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT THANK YOU MAYOR
PRO TEM THE SENATE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY
AT WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE
AM MEMBERS ENJOY YOUR DAY